sounds like you've got a wish
[Applause]
ben's studio has a lot to live up to
especially when one considers the
caliber of exclusives that have come to
call the playstation 4 home
thankfully the developers have managed
to create a leaving breeding world full
of memorable moments characters to love
and hate and creatures to fear
despite having it all wrapped around a
somewhat predictable story that still
manages to hook you in for a long ride
[Music]
exploring the pacific northwest as one
deacon saint john
this post-pandemic woe in this action
adventure is nothing short of
breathtaking
from the forest to snow-capped peaks
mashi swam lands the dilapidated
infrastructure
it all invokes a feeling of time having
passed civilization by followed by an
all-encompassing dread that drums up the
more you stay in this world
hope the tenacity of the human spirit
and the value of relationships are
reflected clearly in the game's dna
a tale starting out as just surviving
gives way so much more as you progress
it becomes a commentary on the human
condition
and the horrors and struggles that
follow
sam witwer who plays deacon saint john
adds nuance and death to a character
that grows on you over time any stellar
supporting cars only makes everything
better
wait hold on cut your engine
of course if there is stun there is gone
that shines the brightest it is the
freakish infected humans who are now
monsters of their own right
the swarmers newts bleachers screamers
breakers reaches and dia animal
counterparts are the biggest threat in
days gone
they roam the world in packs be day and
night often in between you and your goal
the zenith of fear is the horde
masses of freakers that number from the
dozens to the hundreds hungry for your
flesh well the story introduces them
pretty late into the game you can
stumble upon them by chance as they
sleep feed and drink near their nest
taking on a horde is always a calculated
risk going in without a plan is a quick
death
these creatures are brilliant smart
enough to cut you off even as you weave
through obstacles rather than follow in
a straight line
they can scale any height break through
any gaps and their sole purpose is to
reap you the threats
suffice to say every large horde
encounter is simply the highlight of
days gone
humans like the freaker worshipping
rippers and marauders are also
ever-present dangerous
setting up ambushes not just for you but
for the survivors of this harsh world
the living ecosystem much touted by
ben's studio comes to fruition as well
with men animals and freakers all
playing their part you can lead a pack
of freakers through an enemy encampment
and watch chaos and sue or take down the
monsters as they pick through the
remains of their fallen kin or while
hunting deer
the addition of deacon's bike was always
going to raise some eyebrows but riding
your hawk on broken roads mountain paths
and across the world of day days gone
feels tight and responsive
and the experience gets better with
upgrades
with plenty of scrap and fuel cans all
gas stations littered around the world
maintenance is easy fuel allows for fast
travel but given the chance riding is
always much preferred
the progression of gear and upgrades
require you to put in the hard work but
the carats of rewards and the
opportunity to apply dais gone's many
lessons will tide you over easily
deacon saint john is an accomplished
craftsman able to craft many a useful
tool with the right recipe and
ingredients
melee weapons monotops pipe bombs
bandages and more are imperative to
surviving in these guns
utilizing your skills will give you an
advantage focus mode gives you enhanced
aiming while slowing down time while
other upgrades help improve your melee
capabilities and overall survivability
and a fully dectal deacon is a hardened
survivor
health stamina and focus can be further
increased by finding nero injectors
these precious resources are only found
at neuro checkpoints and sites often the
hangout spot of some dangerous freakers
and requires some light puzzle solving
to gain access to
however days gone is not without some
issues
path finding could do with some tweaking
while the enemy ai can go missing
sometimes
stuttering and frame rate drops happen
occasionally and textures can take some
time to load in or not load at all
the pacing of the story also fails to
keep up with player agency
it is weird to learn about the hordes in
terms of story when you have already
encountered them outside in the world
side missions are repetitive but at
least the main story missions are some
of the best fun you can have in an
action adventure
there are also plenty of loading screens
sometimes even between cut scenes so
prepare yourself
band studio's days gone has put together
a world that stands on its own held up
by amazingly realized characters
fearsome adversaries an engaging
gameplay loop that will keep you on your
toes and constantly taking
get in a well-acted character drama and
stay for the freakishly good gameplay
while the worry has been that
playstation exclusives will eventually
run out of steam
days gone carries on the seemingly
unstoppable trend of awesome games only
playable on sony's consoles
[Music]
you